واذا عبرت المانيا عن معارضتها لارسال
ذخائر عنقوديه لاوكرانيا حيث قال وزير
الدفاع الالماني ان ذلك ليس خيارا لبرلين
من جانبها قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
ان لينا بيربو كان بلادها تعارض ذلك ايضا
بصفتها من بين 111 دوله عضوا في اتفاقيه
الذخائر العنقوديه
وتعليقا على اعتزام واشنطن تقديم ذخائر
عنقوديه قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الفرنسيه ان باريس تلتزم بعدم انتاج او
استخدام اسلحه فتاكه واضافت ان بلادها
تتفهم الوضع الذي جعل الولايات المتحده
تسعى لمساعده اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن نفسها
في المقابل قال رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتا
ان بلاده ستتغلب على الصعوبات التي تحاول
بعض الدول خلقها لها واضاف بوتان خلال
اجتماع مع اعضاء مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
نا تلك الدول لم تنجح حتى الان في تحقيق
اهدافها ضد موسكو ولن تنجح في المستقبل
حسب تعبيره
نبحث اليوم الاجراءات التي نعتمدها والتي
يجب ان نعتمدها لتخطي الصعوبات التي
تخلقها بعض الدول امام روسيا حتى اللحظه
لم تحقق ايا من الاهداف التي وضعتها فيما
يتعلق بروسيا ولن تتمكن انا واثق من ذلك